die energiepreise in deutschland die
steigen und steigen und wir bürger
merken das an unserer zeitrechnung wir
merken dass an den zapfsäulen
und es sind die folgen die wir von
putins blutigen angriffskrieg
hierzulande spüren und deswegen gibt es
aus meiner sicht nur eine lösung wir
müssen unabhängig von russischem öl und
gas werden und wir müssen allgemein
unabhängiger von öl und gas werden und
in vielen bereichen auf strom basierte
kraftstoffe wechseln oder auch beim
heizen mehr auf strom setzen die option
dafür die liegen auf dem tisch ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien man kann auf
kohle setzen oder eben auch auf
kernkraft beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
da sind wir uns im land ja weitestgehend
einig das ist sehr sinnvoll denn sonne
und wind die stellen keine rechnung aber
nur mit erneuerbaren können wir keine
ausreichende grundlage kapazität in
deutschland sichern und wir werden auch
nicht die strommengen nur mit
erneuerbaren bekommen die wir in
deutschland benötigen und deswegen muss
man entweder auf kohle setzen zusätzlich
oder auf kernenergie kohle ist aber der
klimakiller nummer eins und kohle ist
extrem umweltschädlich und deswegen
werbe ich dafür dass wir die
klimafreundlichere die co2 freundlichere
form wählen nämlich kernenergie mit
kernenergie können wir wetterunabhängig
und können wir sicher sehr sehr große
mengen strom in deutschland in zukunft
garantieren wir brauchen kernenergie
auch über 2022 hinaus in deutschland
deswegen mein appell an olaf scholz und
robert habeck lassen sie die
kernkraftwerke in deutschland länger
laufen
ich stimme ist ein absolutes ich sage
auch ich glaube dass es richtig ist
ich glaube dass es ganz wichtig ist dass
wir
daran denken dass nationale grenzen für
kernkraftwerke ohnehin keine grenzen
sind das heißt der sicherheitsaspekt
wenn über der grenze darüber irgendein
nicht gut funktionierendes kernkraftwerk
in einem anderen land steht wird uns
nicht größere sicherheit bringen aber
bei dem thema sei da habe ich in den
letzten tagen gehört dass das doch
fraglich ist ob das tatsächlich so
einfach ist und es gäbe nur einem punkt
der mich beunruhigen würde wenn wir aus
opportunitätsgründen
kernkraftwerke versuchen weiter zu
betreiben die eigentlich nicht sicher
sind das wäre für mich das einzige
kriterium wo ich mich sehr gerne auf
professionelle leute verlassen würde
dass sie unpolitisch entscheiden ob man
die kernkraftwerke weiter betreiben kann
und oben nicht in der lage sind in
kurzer zeit kleinere kernkraftwerke
zu bauen das dauert natürlich eine zeit
und bedarf einer grundsatzentscheidung
und ich fände es sehr gut wenn die
politik sich da von dem was in der
vergangenheit entschieden worden ist
entfernt weil man kann auch seine
meinung überdenken man kann auch
hingehen und sagen okay wir haben es
damals so entschieden weil fukushima war
entsetzlich es war ein furchtbares
unglück aber wir müssen einfach jetzt
schauen wo stehen wir und was ist der
preis den wir zahlen sind die
kernkraftwerke sicherer geworden haben
wir eine neue art kleinere
kernkraftwerke zu bauen und dann
unabhängig von dem was man in der
vergangenheit gesagt hat noch mal neu
entscheiden
herr gross wie sehen sie das auch mit
blick auf irland österreich
naja es österreicher wenn ich das nur
darum kraft in die hand nehmen wir
bekomme ich nicht einmal drei prozent
also bei einzug in den bundestag wäre
mir verwehrt so sieht die stimmung in
österreich aus aber ich würde sagen
diese ganze atomkraftdebatte ist der
weitere ausdruck der heuchelei die wir
seit einigen wochen nach rund um die
ukraine krise sehen wir sagen wir
niemand das gas von butte nicht mehr
blut an unserem herdplatten klebte und
nehmen das gas aus katar wird heute um
sexuelle gehängt werden oder frauen
gesteinigt werden und halt dann deren
blut auf unseren heizkörpern klebt wir
sehen nicht was in tschernobyl passiert
ist obwohl das in unsere nachrichten
läuft und auch mit was in fukushima
passiert ist welche unglück diese
unsichere atomkraft über die welt
gebracht hat und ich bin generation 177
ich habe 1986 in einem sandkasten
gespielt wo der sand ausgebaggert werden
musste und wir zwei drei monate erst
kinder nicht ins freie durften bis heute
dürfen wir haben wir ein problem pilze
zu essen weil wir wissen dass sie hohe
zusammen und dennoch gibt es tatsächlich
politiker die diese situation nutzen
oder eine belang sendung für die
atomkraft abführen das ist gut und schön
aber wie gesagt dann sollte man dass das
doch sinnigerweise in der pre machen da
ist der gedenktag ist der tschernobyl
katastrophe
vielleicht kann man das den deutschen
bundesbürger noch einmal ein trägt dann
wie gut und sehen es reicht ja darum
kraft ist vor allem für jene die gern
drei uhren 15 10 und vier augen zweier
zusätzlicher wo wollen sie denn dann in
zukunft energie hernehmen wollen sie die
aus katar wo ich hinwollte natürlich
waren putin bekommen dann müssen die
leute doch ehrlich halter nicht vergeben
natürlich ja bloß ihre ganzen kanzler
helmut kohl erdgas bestellungen in der
sowjetunion noch abgegeben also lügen
wir uns doch nicht in der lage machen
sie jetzt wir haben eine bande
von situationen gehabt die letzten 50
jahre wurde das zk der kpd ist oder
udssr regiert hat und da hat keiner ein
problem gehabt gas zu bestehen aber da
machen so ist ein fehler im moment hab
da man sie machen großen fehler noch
einmal hören sie einmal ganz kurz sehr
groß wir machen einen grossen denkfehler
darauf wollte ich sie kurz einmal
hinweisen die sowjetunion die waren
nicht interessiert daran andere länder
zu überfallen und sich weitere gebiete
anzueignen sondern die verlosten
trotzdem kommt aber kurz lng einmal ganz
los er wollte nur einmal sie auf einen
wichtigen denkfehler aufmerksam machen
die sowjetunion war am status quo
interessiert und daher auch im handel
und hat keine anderen länder angegriffen
russland dagegen ist interessiert daran
grenzen aufzubrechen und die alte
sowjetunion wieder aufleben zu lassen
und ihn mit putin ja oder putin russland
aber erosion an unterstützt ihn so putin
russland ist interessiert daran alte
grenze grenzen aufbrechen zu lassen und
das lohnt deutet dass putin russland und
die sowjetunion nicht zu vergleichen
sind und wenn sie sagen wir beziehen
weiter öl und gas aus russland das
können sie ja machen aber dann sind sie
auch verantwortlich dafür dass das
russische militär auch in zukunft
weitere gelder bekommt um länder wie die
ukraine oder möglicherweise georgien
oder die republik moldau anzugreifen und
das ist aus meiner sicht grund
verantwortlich
die kurze republik ja bloß
erster seine tiefen thailänder
saarländer hat die sowjetunion gesessen
bohlen tschechoslowakei jugoslawien
bulgarien rumänien etc die waren im
einflussbereich sowie mussten sie nicht
der u-bahn erster punkt wenn sie mir mit
dem moralischen vorschlag haben wir
jetzt kommen und sagen erklären sind was
sie mit ihrer gaslieferungen für die
toten in der ukraine verantwortlich
sehen in unserer cleanen und erklären
sie mir wie sie mit ihrem gas inka dafür
die deswegen